well the director of the notebook brings
us another movie that's gonna end up
being a rite of passage that dude's got
a watch if they want a date a girl
all right guys apparently what this
director lives for the other woman
actually be the other other woman
because there's a couple of them anyhow
well the other woman stars Cameron Diaz
she's dating Kings lair from Game of
Thrones things are fine it's going good
then she finds out holy King Slayer
has a wife played by Leslie Mann then
they find out he has another mistress
anyhow these three chicks get together
and now they're gonna get back in it you
know put stuff in his shampoo put
laxatives in his power shake and share
things that really mature adults would
do rather than just divorce to do it and
get it over with and now we have a movie
that chicks can go to together and feel
really empowered while they're waiting
for their first trailer to Sex in the
City 3 it's not good but it's not
terrible it's just not good Leslie Mann
and Cameron Diaz to their credit they do
have good chemistry this third chick I
don't know she said only do I not know
who she is the entire time I was like
you are literally the third wheel even
address it they're like oh yeah I'm a
lawyer and you're the wife and we can
get him and she will find out what she's
good at
right there the Brigham I was telling
you this chick is on screen cuz she has
huge tits to her credit or her parents
credit or gods credit or nature's credit
whoever is to be credited good job guys
for giving us the titty that means is
totally Cameron Diaz and Leslie Mann
here however Leslie Mann oh my god I
have nothing against her as an actress I
think she's a fine actress she's really
good at comedy that's great but in this
movie I was like alright it's 2014 we
can't actually use the term we
haven't been able to do that since the
90s but if this was the 90s I would
probably call her a well her
character not like Leslie Mann herself
but her character her she's a cartoon
the entire movie is absurd sure but she
is the cartoon and this movie had scenes
it didn't really mix it all you're like
why was that scene in there not a huge
scene it's such a small scene you act
any human being who watches it even if
they love this movie to death they're
gonna be like that scene was why was it
in there Cameron Diaz goes on this date
with this dude that she's kind of
crushing on they literally say two
sentences to each other and then it's
the next scene it's not like they wake
up together or anything it's just the
next scene it's the next morning and
then the movie
was on your like why the date thing good
it feels like when you're having a
conversation with a friend and that
really awkward friend of a friend tries
to energy action you just kind of go
yeah yeah and then you just go back to
the conversation that's what that scene
was and then they're gonna follow
Kingslayer he knows that they're
tracking them and they're following him
in a car that is literally one car
lengths behind his car I'm like hey TJ
and the hookers back it up a bit does by
a bit I mean like a city block you never
follows someone who put their facebook
status to private guys he's a rookie
mistakes you make so the movie had cheap
laughs less than a man in Cameron Diaz
they did work well together Leslie Mann
was odd and bizarre and I just didn't
get why she had to be that weird the
sisters before misters might have a
pretty good time at the movie but all in
all to be honest with you guys this
movie would be a lot better if you're
drunk ya know it's a party go girl
why am i watching this movie because you
have a girlfriend man it's just the way
it's gonna be or so the other woman not
the Natalie Portman movie the other
other woman have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]